all right we are here at the oscars yes
that's right
when movie lovers unite and watch tv
[Music]
this year the academy hired three women
to host because it's cheaper than hiring
one man
it's fun right
right you're right right
but i'm still excited to be hosting
representing black women who are
standing proud yes and i'm and living
out loud yes yes yes
and i
am representing unbearable white women
who call the cops when you get a little
too loud
[Applause]
you know we've been dealing with covet
for two years it's been really hard on
people yeah i mean just
look at timothy chalamet
oh god
what happened i don't know it's not good
it's not good you know what
i'd still smash
okay
wow wow yeah
as many of you know a decision was made
to present some behind-the-scene awards
in the first hour yeah it was a
controversial and difficult decision but
you know i think we've moved on yeah
[Music]
wait a minute look look we're all unions
yeah
come on that's not our decision you know
uh there was a lot of snubs this year
yeah yeah rachel zegler for west side
story
yeah jennifer hudson for respect
and lady gaga and jared leto for house
of random accents
[Applause]
this is kind of sad you know what's uh
what's in the in memoriam package this
year
the golden globes
they didn't have any black people they
didn't have any black members oh they
had to go you know i was very
disappointed that space jam 2 did not
get nominated in the special effects
category for that hairline they gave
lebron james oh my god amazing it was
really good it was really good
black twitter is gonna love that one i
think so
yeah what is that no you don't
don't it's not it's not for you okay
stay away
you know this year we saw a frightening
display of how toxic masculinity turns
into cruelty towards women and children
damn that mitch mcconnell i know
i know
but you know i was actually talking
about the power of the dog oh yes
you know um i watched that movie three
times and i'm halfway through it yeah
yeah you're the best part yeah no no no
yeah yeah one more week and you're in
there stay with us yeah stay with us
you know samuel l jackson is here
yes
there he is
he just got the governor's award for his
lifetime body of work
did you just ask samuel l jackson
i mean i i love him you know he's my guy
but i'm gonna be honest there's a few
holes in his resume yeah
no for real like like where's the sam
jackson rom-com
like like like where's the you know sam
jackson and jennifer lewis and when this
mofo met that mofo
you know order sequel [ __ ] i said i
love you
no you know what he likes it he likes it
[Applause]
you're right and where is his musical
rent
ho i said where's my rent there you go
i'd stream that yeah
no that's good well
we're gonna have a great night uh
tonight and for you people in florida
we're gonna have a gay night
we're your oscar hosts i'm wanda sykes
i'm amy schumer and i'm
single okay boy
i mean it's not the time for that i'm
providing the soundtrack for the next
hour give it up for the incomparable
dnase
welcome everybody
[Applause]
you